تخبط شديد للجمهوريين بعد فشلهم في تحقيق
موجه حمراء في انتخابات نوفمبر كما ارادوا
على الاقل والان ورغم فوزهم بمجلس النواب
لا يستطيعون انتخاب رئيس لمجلس النواب
ترامب دع الجمهوريين اليوم الى التصويت
لمكارسي اذن وهو لم يكن موقف ترامب امس او
في ايام الغموض الماضيه حينما احجم عن
دعمه بشكل علني كما كان يقول حسين وهو
يعتبر معتدلا ولا يرى ترامب مع مساعدين
وحلفاء بانه دعموا في تحقيقات احداث يناير
في الكابل ترامب سحب من مكارثي الدعم بحجه
انه لا يقف خلف الجيولوجيهته بشكل كامل
وبالتالي اغضب اعضاء جمهوريين تعد اصواتهم
حاسمه لحسم منصب رئيس مجلس النواب كسب بعض
وخسر البعض امس تجنب ترامب الرد على سؤال
من شبكه ام بي سي نيوز حول دعمه لمقارتي
ولم يرد على السؤال للمباشر ليقول سنرى ما
سيحدث ويضيف ترامب بشكل النصي العديد من
النواب ارادوا الحصول على دعم لقد اتصل
بالجميع هذا كل ما يمكنني قوله سنرى كذب
كيف سينتهي هذا الامر انتهى الامر اليوم
باعلان ترامب انه يدعم مكه لكن يظل عدد من
حلفاء الرئيس السابق يرون المرشح لرئيس
مجلس النواب بمظهر لين مع الديمقراطيين
[موسيقى]
بالامريكي وسالتهم عن ما اذا كانترست يقوم
بعمل جيد وعم اذا كانوا يحبون الطريقه
التي تدار بها الامور في واشنطن من
المحتمل ان تسمع رفضهم للطريقه التي تدار
بها الامور بشكل كبير نريد تغيير الطريقه
التي تتم بها الاموره
لا يستحق ان يكون في منصب رئيس مجلس
النواب وصوت الى جانبي 19 جمهوريا اخرين
بالامس للنائب من ولايه اوهايو جيم جورد
رغم ترامب في دعمه الاخير في قال انه
سيقوم بعمل رائع حينما يصبح رئيسا وعلى
الجمهوريين متابعه ذلك
ابن خالتي
لكنه رفضها سعينا للتصويت في الربع الاول
من الكونغرس 118 على حدود الفتره لقد رفض
اردنا ميزانيه من لجنه الدراسه الجمهوريه
في الربع الاول رفض ردنا خطه الحدود التي
وضعها وفد تكساس على الارض لقد رفض نحن
نعاني من ازمه ثقه مع ذكر
اليوم في رساله دعم ترامب قال ان على
الجمهوريين عدم تحويل الانتصار الكبير في
الانتخابات الى هزيمه هائله لكن يبدو ان
الدعم وصل متاخرا يقول انه تمت الكثير من
المحادثات بعد فشل المقارتي في الحصول على
التصويت وقد حان الوقت الان لجميع الاعضاء
الجمهوريين بان يصوت لصالح كارثي وانهاء
هذا الامر ولم يترك ترامب غرينته السياسيه
دون انتقاد في رسالته واكد ان التصويت
لمكارسي يعني سال نانسي بيلوسي الى منزلها
في كاليفورنيا وهي مكسوره ويتمتع
الجمهوريون باغلبيه بسيطه في مجلس النواب
ب22 مقعدا مقابل 212 مقعدا وقد تسبب
انشقاقه النواب الجمهوريين في احراج للحزب
[موسيقى]
احدى العثرات امام فوز مكارثي هي اعتقاد
البعض في الجناح اليمني للحزبه ان مطار في
لا يدين بالولاء بدرجه كافيه لترامب الذي
سيخوض سباق البيت الابيض مجددا ياتي ذلك
رغم ان مقار في مثلا رفض ان يمتل امام
اللجنه التي تحقق في احداث اقتحام الكابتل
عام 2021 في اشاره دعم واضحه لترامب كما
وعدت الاعضاء الجمهوريين اليمنيين باجراء
تحقيقات تطلب ايضا وعائلته واداراته اضافه
الى مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ووكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه وهو الامر الذي يجعل
مكار في يسير على خيط رفيعه حيث قد يراه
الوسطيون في الحزب الجمهوريه انه يرضى كل
اليمين ما يعني احتمال نايهم عنه
[موسيقى]